mr president is it true that we're going
to give 450 000 to border crossers
who were separated
heads scratching silence did you see it
quick look there on the escalator
that's all president biden offered when
he was questioned on a wall street
journal report the story
his administration may pay 450 thousand
dollars per person
to people who come here who sued over
the trump administration separating them
at the border
republicans are tearing into the
president over the idea that could cost
some one million dollars per family and
as much as one billion dollars overall
here's senator marcia blackburn on the
faulkner focus asking
how that must make hard-working american
families feel
we would like to know
what legal authority
that he is using to have dhs hhs and
the department of justice go negotiate
these prepayments to these individuals
that have broken the law
at the southern border as they came into
this country and now they get this they
get free benefits they get free health
care
people are really not happy with what
joe biden is delivering and it's why
they're moving away from him
mark brnovich attorney for the great
state of arizona attorney general is in
focus now
so talk to me about exactly what the
senator was asking about what legal
authority does the president of the
united states have to do this
well thank you harris for having me on
and as you know president biden
has been untethered to the constitution
any legal authority since day one of
since day one of his administration as
you know we have multiple lawsuits in
fact literally on friday the u.s supreme
court accepted our case involving the
public charge rule which the by demand
administration abandoned their defense
of a statute that basically are a rule
that says you have to be able to support
yourself this is what i call
incentivizing people to come here and
now you throw on top of this their
unwillingness to enforce existing law
and now essentially monetizing giving
people payments close to half a million
dollars that have broken the law it's
quite frankly not only unconstitutional
it's unconscionable and i've got an idea
i've got an idea here breaking news
instead of giving them 450 000 in
hard-working american taxpayer cash
let's give them all a joe biden or a 100
biden painting they can have a hundred
biden painting we'll call it all equal
wow real quickly i wrote that down biden
has been untethered to the
constitutional i have to think
that states are going to fight this and
now we're all kind of border states
because look at this the new york post
is reporting the border crisis has hit
classrooms after the biden
administration flew unaccompanied minors
to new york in the cover of darkness
well we've been reporting that right new
york new jersey florida they write four
counties alone suffolk queens nassau and
brooklyn took in nearly 5 000
unaccompanied children in just 11 months
and the arrival of these children mostly
teenage boys in local schools is
creating a classroom crisis that is
strapping educational resources costing
taxpayers millions of dollars in
unbudgeted expenses and aiding gang
recruiting efforts
argue parents teachers and immigration
experts do they have a point with all of
that and what can be done
absolutely they have a point and i was a
gang prosecutor and the cartels have
seized operational control of our border
so americans will die they will be
affected on in unimaginable ways so it's
not only the fiscal cost the fiscal
impacts for the schools the hospitals in
our and our social safety network that
so many hard-working taxpayers put into
but it's also the fact that the gangs
now are pushing drugs into our country
we know i know as a prosecutor the price
of fentanyl is falling because there are
more of these dangerous drugs coming
into our our state and that is not
staying in arizona it is going to be in
new york it's going to be in kansas it's
going to be all over this country right
and it's what i was saying making
technically all of us in border states
at that point we're all feeling it real
real quickly i just want to understand
how you get because it's not all boys
who are coming across the border do we
even have the resources to find out who
we should be looking for at this point
well we need to start harris with
enforcing the law as it is i mean as you
know there will be the more than two
million people
illegally crossing our southern border
just this year it's more than twice it's
like two of biden home states of
delaware if he understands what the
population of the state still is or
whoever's speaking in his earpiece so
this is overwhelming the social network
and the cartels have seized control
they're exploiting women on that are
coming into this country some of them
have to work that off uh by being
trafficked and enslaved um within
terrible conditions and we know that the
drugs that are coming into this country
is going to fuel violence in our inner
cities and it's going to end up with a
terrible epidemic with our kids dying of
drug overdoses or becoming addicted to
drugs and you're not just you know
looking out and sort of forecasting
you're looking based on the evidence
that we have right now and and that's
what we did to get more than two and a
half million by the end of the year i
mean by the time we had a million and a
half a few weeks ago just do the math
all right let's move to this so many
virginia parents because you know we're
focused on that virginia governor's race
with a republican now on issues like
this has taken the lead um so many of
these parents have had it with critical
race theory here's louden county a mom
there
my six-year-old somberly came to me and
asked me if she was born evil because
she was a white person something she
learned in a history lesson at school i
refuse to allow you to destroy our
schools they are not your schools they
are our schools
meanwhile america's top law enforcement
officer attorney general merrick
garland's memo that threatened parents
at school board meetings still stands we
know we heard from in hearings last week
he doesn't apologize he's not taken
aback but gop house oversight committee
members continue to pursue a hearing of
their own on it here's republican jim
jordan
i think our our first amendment liberty
is every single one of them you're right
to practice your faith your right to
assemble right to petition your
government freedom of the press freedom
of speech i think they've all been
assaulted over the last year by the left
what the attorney general did a week and
a half ago during this hearing we
brought this to light but when he issued
that memo basically setting up a snitch
line on parents who show up at school
board meetings to stand up for their
kids and make sure this racist
anti-american curriculum critical race
theory is not taught in our schools what
he did was so wrong
let's ask an attorney general mark
brnovich your thoughts
joe biden and merrick garland
essentially want to weaponize or
continue to weaponize the department of
justice and just because parents are
exercising their first amendment rights
to speak out against critical race
theory or even vaccine mandates does not
make them domestic terrorists and if we
allow the bite administration to
continue this god forbid you're going to
end up with mom and pop at gitmo think
about how outrageous that is harris to
think about that that is outrageous
could that really happen
we are living in a time where we all
need to make sure that we are protecting
our constitutional rights on every
single level from the local school board
levels to the state and especially on
the federal level that's interesting
because you say one leads to the other
that sounds like a slippery slope which
is how you got there uh mark brnovich
thank you for being in focus hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now